I've always known I would marry rich why
should I be ashamed of that into nothing
to be ashamed of as long as you love him
well I believe we have some power over
who we love it isn't something that just
happens to a person I think the poet's
night disagree well I'm not a poet I'm
just a woman and as a woman there's no
way for me to make my own money not
enough to earn a living or to support my
family and if I had my own money which I
don't that money would belong to my
husband the moment we got married and if
we had children they would be his not
mine they would be his property so don't
sit there and tell me that marriage
isn't an economic proposition because it
is may not be for you but it most
certainly is for me
[Music]
is it fairies Santa Claus it's all don't
watch sister Lord sent to France please
Quinn [ __ ] yes he saw him giving you
Christmas breakfast away and he wanted
you to enjoy the day but I thought he
was a mean old man so generous is him
his grandson Laurie put the idea into
his head I know he did
we should make friends with him boys
scare me that big old house here's me
Jenny Snow says that mr. Lawrence
disowned his son after he went off with
an Italian woman and now his grandson is
important and he spent all this time in
that house locked up with his tutor he's
a very kind man who lost his little girl
when she was only a child and now his
son is gone daughter died that's what
doesn't Laurie just seem so romantic
he's half Italian when I get in a
passion I get so Savage I could hurt
anyone and I'd enjoyed it you remind me
of myself
you're never angry I'm angry nearly
every day of my life you want I'm not
patient by nature but with nearly 40
years of effort I'm learning to not let
it get the better of me
I'll do the same I hope you'll do a
great deal better than me there are some
nature's too noble to curb and too often
bad so would you like to dance with me I
can't because because what you won't
tell never i scorched my dress see there
and Meg told me to keep still so no one
would see it you can laugh if you want
to it's funny I know I have an idea of
how we can manage
[Music]
I just I just feel I just feel like
women the they have minds and they have
souls as well as just hearts and they've
got ambition and they've got talent as
well as just beauty and I'm so sick of
people saying that that love is just all
a woman is fit for I'm so sick of it I'm
so lonely Josephine
yes yeah is there a reason you stopped
reading Belgium I'm sorry I'll continue
you mind yourself dearie
someday you'll need me you'll wish you
have behaved better thank you out March
for your employment and your many
kindnesses but I intend to make my own
way in the world oh no no one makes
their own way not really
least of all a woman you'll need to
marry well but you are not married
aren't well that's because I'm rich I'm
working on a novel
it is a story of my life and my sisters
make it short and spicy and if the main
character is a girl make sure she's
married by the end
I want to be an artist in Rome and be
the best painter in the louver offs what
you want to isn't a Joe to be a famous
right yes well it sounds so crass when
she says my girls have a way of getting
into mischief
oh so do I this is Meg Amy Beth and Joe
I intend to make my own way in the world
no one makes their own way least of all
a woman you'll need to marry well you
are not married not well that's because
I'm rich
[Music]
don't would you like to dance with me I
can't because I scorched my dress and
you made told me to keep still so no one
would see it I'm idiomatic
Joe is lost cause
that's who are your families hope now
I believe we have some power over who we
love it isn't something that just
happens to a person
I think the poets night - suey we can
leave right now
I'll sell stories join you here should
be an actress and you should have a life
on the stage just because my dreams are
different than yours doesn't mean
they're unimportant new play written by
miss Jo Moss women they have minds and
they have souls as well as just hearts I
want to be great or nothing
and they've got ambition and they've got
talent as well as just beauty I'm so
sick of people saying that love is just
all of the minutes
[Music]
there are some nature's - Laughing Man
so who does she marry
[Music]